[Music]
a military plane has crashed in the
philippines killing at least 17 people
the c-130 was trying to land on hollow
island in sulu province
so far 40 of those on board have been
rescued and troops
are looking for others let's go live to
jamila allendogen who is in manila
jamila what more do we know
well kim what we know is that the c-130
took off at around 11 30 a.m local time
from kagayandi oro province
which is one of the biggest cities in
the southern region of
mindanao and it was according to the
secretary of defense figured in a
landing mishap
um a few hours later um it landed in
patikul which is the next town
after hola um we were told that medivac
medical evacuation helicopters are are
are on their way
and that those who are uh have been
recovered who are injured are being
taken to the nearest military station
hospital in halo
those who are critically injured will be
flown to zamboanga city which is the
biggest
city closest to hollow according to
the government the latest numbers show
that 17 bodies have been pulled out
around 40
have been injured but that number may
rise they fear that
some bodies may be pulled out in the
coming hours now
khala is the most militarized area in
the southern philippines it's home to
thousands of troops
and also home to several armed groups
like the more islamic liberation front
the more national liberation front and
the abu sayyaf group now we were told
that around 85 personnel who came from
another division
in another part of mindanao and we're
reporting for duty when the accident
happened kim
all right uh we'll be checking back in
with you as more comes to hand no doubt
for now thank you for that jamilah
allendogen in manila